I am going into this a tad bit concerned
but we have a great you know research
department I'm sure they would have put
me in any real danger right right maybe
where'd you want a soup cleanse
apparently it's healthy I'm not sure
I've heard questionable things about
cleanses one other time in my life I
attempted to do a juice cleanse keyword
being attempted because I quit after day
two I don't even like soup that much
everyone else loves soup I'm not the
biggest soup head hey I'm the world's
biggest suit fan that's what I'm trying
to say here I'm a I'm those just a soup
guy I don't know
cuz I like testing myself
a soup cleanse is different than any
other kind of liquid cleanse that you
might have because we make sure that we
have all the nutrition that your body
needs in a day so the super arrives in
this giant bag and there is a lot of
soup this is so heavy
yes is like a baby this is going to be
inside me by end of the day and I'm
straining to wholeness as with anything
new the first day wasn't the worst I am
eating the chicken broth soup for the
first time that's actually like really
good there were a lot more soups than I
thought there'd be a wide variety I
thought the soups were amazing they were
the best part of the whole experience
today is the end of day 1 for the most
part the day was pretty good definitely
the worst and hardest part of all of
this was going out to eat with other
people who were eating delicious food
delicious salad they're literally joy
[ __ ] cake this is like not even real
right now I feel like at the end of this
to cleanse I'm just not gonna have a ton
left I burned myself I'm probably every
damn soup I had and like it's because I
was so hungry that like I just wanted to
pour it all down my throat I didn't
really feel that hungry throughout the
cleanse
I generally felt pretty full it's day 2
of the cleanse and there's a lot of
pizza here there's a lot of pizza it was
hard to say no to pizza it was really
hard to say no to pizza and Shane and I
cannot indulge in any I feel like the
beer is fine yeah beers a soup you were
right about that I mean well it's a
liquid I probably took this less
seriously than everyone else Jen gave me
permission
eles I had some cookies and beer and
pizza I'm actually like heartbroken with
this because I told ja like you know I
wanted to commit nothing else just soup
barely water that's it
I had a handful enough look what is
happening this is the one still this
fell I knocked my soup over this would
not have happened if it was a solid meal
my energy level by the third day was
trash today is one of the biggest shoot
days of the year for me and
unfortunately it has lined up you know
with the soup cleanse which is an ideal
but uh that's the world I live in right
now my boyfriend just kept begging me to
eat something because he said I wasn't
being very nice to him I was kind of
grumpy it's 9 o'clock at night
I'm so hungry and I'm cooking my last
soup this is the final bit of soup of
the entire cleanse i'ma go eat til I die
this soup plans went a lot better than I
thought it would in terms of positive
affect I lost 2 pounds which was kind of
nice
this was bearable to me because I felt
like I was eating foods too I would
definitely do a one day cleanse again I
feel like after the first day I felt
really good I got very tired of soup
that's my big takeaway you know I'm
still not a stupid I'm still not in love
with soup but maybe I could be convinced